[Musique]
dans le cadre de la journée mondiale de
l'environnement le projet endémie elle a
été lancée ce mercredi 5 juin bourg
murat
un projet qui a pour but de lutter
contre les espèces exotiques
envahissantes et contre le braconnage en
plantant des espèces endémiques et
indigènes 52 mille arbres et arbustes
mais ni faire de 48 espèces différentes
seront donc planté le projet ondée miel
est un projet qui consiste à planter
massivement des espèces indigènes et
endémiques mellifères de la réunion le
long d'un corridor écologique de 36 km
qui partira de 420 à 1600 mètres
d'altitude sur le territoire a tamponné
nous les hommes femmes et enfants ça ou
de babel nature par tous que nous sommes
tous que nous représentons et on doit
prendre conscience unis à l'occasion de
la journée mondiale de l'environnement
que le projet en est mais c'est un
signal qu'on donne à l'humanité à notre
pays à la réunion est au top ne peut
dire qu'il faut s'occuper de son
environnement suisse de la bière deux
planètes et de faire en sorte que nous
laissions à nos enfants puis unis la
commune soit agréable vivre au calme
possible riche en projets innovants qui
bénéficie d'une subvention de l'état de
500 mille euros et a participé au
financement dans des miels à plus de 50%
cinq cent mille euros parce que c'est un
projet pilote un projet novateur et un
projet de reconquête de la biodiversité
c'est très important et moi je suis très
heureux de participer à cette
manifestation partenariale le projet est
également soutenu par le département
le président séry maker souhaite même
dupliquer l'opération sur les routes
départementales
quand vous voyez on est capable de
produire du miel comme ça c'est génial
vert à partir des plantes endémiques de
la réunion comme le thon rouge
on ne peut qu apporter notre soutien et
moi je veux d'une réunion
réserver aujourd'hui toutes les actions
que nous devons mener doivent contribuer
à sauvegarder l'humanité et cela passe
par la préservation des espèces
endémiques de la réunion une plantation
symbolique de tan rouge a clôturé la
matinée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]